[Music]
unions will take a major blow in the
upcoming Janus versus ask me case if the
Supreme Court rules that agency fees are
unconstitutional agency fees which some
states require non-union employees to
pay unions for representation have been
a lynchpin of union membership take the
NEA America's largest teachers union the
22 states with agency fees are home to
69% of NEA members agency fees are
pivotal because they change the cost of
union membership take California
teachers can pay a thousand dollars to
join the union or not join but still pay
six hundred and fifty dollars in agency
fees with no fees teachers choose to pay
a thousand dollars or zero as the cost
of joining Soares union membership will
fall
no one knows by how much but since 2010
three States dropped agency fees and in
them the NEA shrank between 17 and 59
percent a defeat in Janice will weaken
America's most powerful education
interest groups the long-term question
is by how much for more on Janice agency
fees and why they are so important for
teachers union membership check the
links in the description below also let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI